antoine bonjour alors pour lutter contre
la crise sanitaire la capitale russe a
pris des mesures plus strictes du
contrôle par rapport au confinement en
quoi consistent les nouvelles mesures
oui la ville de moscou qui compte à elle
seule les trois cinquièmes des cas
confirmés en russie vient en effet de
renforcer son dispositif depuis ce lundi
un système de laissez-passer
électroniques a été mise en place pour
toutes personnes voulant se déplacer
dans la ville que ce soit avec son
véhicule personnel ou bien en transport
en commun à laisser passer qui depuis ce
matin est devenu obligatoire pour tous
obligatoire pour tout déplacement afin
de se rendre dans un établissement
médical ou bien sur son lieu de travail
quand on le peut exercer son activité à
distance et les contrôles de police sont
fréquents sur les routes toute personne
qui n'est pas en règle et refoulé et
renvoyés d'où elle vient dans le métro
par contre les contrôles vont être
automatisées et karine généré d'immenses
que ce qui n'est pas idéal dans un
contexte de distanciation social pour
l'instant il n'est pas utile d'en avoir
un pour aller à la pharmacie ou au
supermarché ou encore promener son chien
ou descendre ses poubelles et pour
obtenir ce laissez passer
il suffit de le commander sur le site de
la mairie de moscou par téléphone ou
encore par sms les autorités municipales
espèrent ainsi enrayer la hausse
inquiétante des cas de coronavirus 1774
nouveaux cas ces dernières 24 heures
rien qu'à moscou pour un total de près
de 15000 personnes affectées dans la
capitale russe antoine merci à beaucoup
pour toutes ces précisions je rappelle
que vous êtes en direct de moscou